What's cracking, s-squad fam?
//dab dab
It's ya boi
P-PewriePie here
It's time for an update video
I-it's been awhile
I'm gonna try and keep it brief
But you know I would love to make this shit ten minutes if I could (laughs)
Uum, for real I just wanted to
U͐ͦ̉PD̞AT̑ͦ̚E̩ Y̤̕OͦU̢͛̕ G̡̎͒U̖̐͋Y̗͋̒S
on uh what's going on
First of all, I just wanted to say
Uh, thank you
I realized, uh,
Something uh really great the other day, and I think it's that I finally
Enjoy my audience again (laughs)
Sorry Edgar, you're not invited. Okay?
I still don't enjoy you, go away.
That's not to say that I never uh -
enjoyed my audience. I think back in the day,
when I was starting off, there was so much just positivity and eh
everyone was on the same page on the channel, and then
Since it grew bigger than it probably ever should have... Um...
We-it got such a mix of different people that wanted different content
and eh it just sort of became a thing where
no matter what I uploaded there's always gonna be people nagging
a lot of nagging and complaining constantly, and i-it's...
You shut that out and obviously it's not fair because a lot of people are still really cool and still, uh,
Supporting what you do, but for a long time, I just felt like
Y-You look at your audience as a whole and you're just like 'Jesus fucking christ. What do you want from me?' Um, (laughs)
But I feel now when I've taken a less serious approach to YouTube and uh taking it more casual
It's sort of ...brought back, uh...
I'm doing these weekly...um...weekly..um
fan interaction videos
it sort of brought back an audience that I can remember
That seemed really cool and really on the same page, and I'm really happy about that
I'm just really happy that I have an audience that I rea- actually really like
I used to have just all kids watching me back in the day and
that's fine, but it also sort of makes you question what the fuck you're doing
I'll still--I still get comments though. Saying
" Only 12 year olds watch Pewdiepie--
scream, while he plays horror games!!1!11"
But anyway...uh, you guys are okay
is what I'm trying to say
but yeah, I've been... like I said, I've been taking a more---
Easier approach to YouTube and I also think that's made my content--
less forced,
it's just what it is
You know if I feel like I'm gonna just play a game
Uh,  I'm just gonna play a game, and you guys have seemed really okay with that like
that's really cool
And I'm happy about that
I'm very just happy about that again
And I just been doing what I want to do which sort of led me to just enjoy video games again
It's been--it's been a while!
I actually enjoy playing video games
and sharing that with you guys
so I think that's---
That's something I want to keep doing so--
to sort of fill the more time that I have now, in between making videos
I thought I wanna... I want to start streaming
So I'm gonna start streaming Monday to Friday at least
I'll be.. I'll probably be live
between 12:00 P- 12:00 P.M. Uk
to 4- at least 4 / 5 P.M.
British time
not sure what time that is for you,
probably doesn't work out for you but that-
That's the time I'm gonna be live
and I'm pretty excited about that
I think live streams is one of my favorite things.
I realized this is a very boring
update video (laughs)
But I just wanted to let you guys know what's going on,
and I really just a-again, I just want to say thank you
I'm very very happy that I have an audience that I enjoy, and uh also
Thank you for all the support on the merch that we did
it was a huge success
I'm so happy that you guys bought the merch
I legit had merch in the past
where
like three people bought one (laughs)
I'm not joking (laughs)
and then you have to explain to the people that helped you make it be like 'Well,
I guess people didn't like it.' and it's not like you have to buy merch to support me
But i-it it shows that.. it means a lot, it just means a lot and uh I want just thank you, thank you
well, there's no way I can make this ten minutes,
so I'm just gonna end it here.
I'll see you in the live streams
I'll see you bros in the--sisters--in the
videos
and uh again just uhh...
keep sucking dick
*wink
*kiss